a second speaker is one that you might
already know he's continually active in
our community
these days you will find him working on
topics like
how to build data science teams
operationalizing ai
or data centers on graphs and more so it
was a tough choice
to pick just one topic for tonight we
settled on
automated machine learning or order ml
so please welcome paco nathan parkway
there
thank you thank you very much christian
wonderful uh thank you i really
appreciate the opportunity
to uh present here and uh thank you very
much to ibm for
for sponsoring i i've been uh helping
out with the
ibm data science community for a while
and uh it's uh it's very active um
we've had some some wonderful events and
uh always
a lot of ongoing discussions um
this talk here is a survey about automl
i'll start with the slides here in a
moment but um
just to give a little bit of background
um
you know this this field is interesting
it's been developing for a while
uh we can definitely point back to some
very key papers
about a decade ago taking a look at say
stephen boyd's work at stanford on adm
uh and the whole idea of leveraging
convex optimization to come out with
uh you know optimal models um
and and there's similar work by uh you
know emitted walker and
and others uh following up on that um
so this field has been emerging it's
largely about using machine learning uh
to have better machine learning i think
it's probably a good way to put it uh
about
three years ago my colleague and
co-author uh
ben lorica was a gradient flow uh ben of
course used to
lead the o'reilly ai conference and
strata data conference and others um ben
had asked for more of a
business overview of what was going on
in this space
and so i'd done a report done some talks
and
we'd published a little bit about it but
then
early last year um my
my friends at ibm my colleagues also my
co-author
uh will roberts uh you know they asked
let's take a little bit more of a
hands-on perspective
and really focusing on the open source
and showing people
uh a lot of pointers toward how to get
started in this area
and and of course since then in the past
couple of years uh this area has really
taken off so
the talk today is more of an
introduction
uh coming from the perspective of being
a developer or a data scientist
um what's going on in this field and
really you know what are the ideas and
the key points
um because i think that there's been uh
how shall i say politely a lot of
marketing
and so a lot of information that maybe
isn't quite the most balanced
so i want to try to just bring out like
what are the issues and where are some
really great resources if you want to
get started
and so having said that let me
i'll share my entire desktop just
because i want to switch back and forth
between the presentation
and maybe also
some views um on on a web browser
um okay so let's presenter
alrighty can you see that okay
good okay okay um well first off
thank you very much to ibm data science
community um
and uh here's a link for me if you want
to get a hold of me on twitter or
or webpage at darren um
you know to to talk about automl
um first off i want to throw up this
idea
and it's really conceptual uh but the
idea is
you probably have a gradient problem so
when we're talking about machine
learning
especially when we look at supervised
learning but also other areas machine
learning
we like to understand data in terms of
gradients differentiable gradients
and we could do a deep dive into the
math and talk about manifolds and
all some of the theory on this but at
the end of the day
what we're talking about uh are
generally ways to
learn from how to differentiate the data
because
it's arranged in some sort of gradient
and we create
on one hand features to really
accentuate
those kind of gradients uh nandita was
showing a lot of that i love the
visualization of features you know going
into some of the
the feature engineering in previous talk
um but we also create
learners and algorithms that are based
off of loss functions and regularization
etc
uh to be able to leverage the gradients
and so if we if we take a look inside of
a really common example
let me switch to showing this notebook
okay this is just a very simple
example using iris the data set
of three different species of iris
flower it's you know a century old now
um i just loaded it up from scikit-learn
and then using numpy and pandas will
load a data frame with the data set
and what you get are the species there's
a categorical
variable uh defining what you're trying
to predict
and then you get four different columns
of
links and widths and whatnot of of parts
of the flower
now if we visualize that we can take a
look using seabourn
and we can see that the three different
species
when visualized based on some of these
features
it's differentiated you know definitely
when you look at
at some of these they have more
predictive power than others but like
for instance here
looking at pedal width versus pedal
length you can really see how the three
different species are sort of
spread out spatially and
when we're training machine learning
algorithms of course this is what we're
using
is that kind of of differentiation
and just here's a real simple example of
building a test and train set in psychic
learn and then running a random forest
classifier
uh training that and you know the
decision
when you're when you're working with
supervised learning typically there's
some sort of parameters
and so in the case uh well actually with
random forest you
you're going to choose how many trees
you're going to have
um that's the main parameter that you're
trying to decide so
um the idea with random forest is if you
have only one tree it's just sort of
defaults into being a decision tree
if you have a lot of trees then you can
capture a lot of edge cases so to speak
and you also have some nice benefits of
outband error
being able to predict what the accuracy
of the model is as soon as it's trained
a lot of great properties at a random
forest so
if we plot uh here
let's pick a lot of a range of different
values for that parameter the number of
trees then we can also plot what is
the the loss uh
taking accuracy score um what is the
loss
uh that we're seeing what kind of
accuracy or particular power are we
seeing
out of this algorithm and it's
interesting random force you know if you
keep throwing
more and more trees you get better and
better results out to a point
uh if you keep throwing a lot more trees
then eventually you start to see
little hiccups like this where you
probably have too many trees going on
you're getting some other effects
so yeah we could probably pick like 15
trees would be good here
and that's visually we're just
eyeballing it so the question is
can we train machine learning models to
recognize that and
automatically pick those kinds of
parameters
and that's a lot of the just for for at
least parts of
automl and let me
zoom is kind of in the way of my screen
so let me see here okay
so with the iris data set here if we
look at say pedal width versus sepal
length
uh just to take a look at at two
features we can get a pretty good
separation
a little bit of overlap um we have a
learner
which is our random forest algorithm
there's a loss function i won't go into
the math too much but
um basically two parts of the algorithm
are the loss function the
regulation term we can define those then
we can run
a gradient descent algorithm to try to
pull the pieces apart and
train the learners to come up with a
good model
now this is looking inside this
algorithm
we have this notion of parameters versus
hyperparameters
uh the hyper parameters are what i
mentioned the number of trees that's
something that you select
when you're going to go and use some
kind of machine learning algorithm
there's also the notion of a parameter
which is what the learners what the
algorithm selects
it's sort of the elements in the model
for how it's learned to differentiate
the gradient how to predict the species
now in the case of random forest you
know we can
determine based on how many trees we
have how many parameters there will be
in in terms of hyperparameters is really
just the one
for some of the older forms of
supervised machine learning of course
there's usually not a lot of hyper
parameters
um and now there'll be some parameters
here but
as we're getting into deep learning and
and really
large architectures of neural networks
you know we've been seeing these models
that have a billion parameters
and more and now some of the latest
coming out of open ai and google and
whatnot
we're seeing even trillion parameter
models
so with just a few hyper parameters we
can
create some pretty big models that means
that there's a pretty large decision
space there in terms of how those are
selected
um now this is a generalization so you
know take it with a grain of salt but
i wanted we wanted to compare a bit
about different forms of machine
learning
um certainly with with supervised
learning you're differentiating
gradients
of uh uh input features
to try to predict some sort of label or
some sort of value
so independent and dependent variables
with unsupervised learning it's much the
same
uh it's just that you really don't have
the labels to work with the algorithm
is generating proxies for that so you
know a very well-known form of
unsupervised learning of course would be
like clustering
k-means clustering is an example and
instead of having labels you have
cluster centers
which are sort of proxies for that
active learning is a really super
interesting area there's
unfortunately active learning is used in
a couple different ways but for machine
learning
uh it's it's where you have human in the
loop with supervised learning
you know effectively you can you can
leverage the uncertainty uh that the
model
is highlighting spotlighting uh you can
basically search for regions of
uncertainty in your training set
and then when there's a high enough
threshold
kick out uh the the judgment the
decision to
an expert who will then label that data
point
and provide it as feedback and you can
train with
with more data that way there's also a
notion of self-supervision which is to
say
i have a complex object and i want to
build machine learning models to
recognize it
can i sample parts of the object
and use that to predict other parts of
the object so
as far as machine learning model is
concerned parts are known and parts are
unknown
so i'm kind of hiding parts of my data
to to
be able to construct something that's
like unsupervised learning but then
shift it over into more supervision
and self-supervised pipelines are really
interesting facebook's been doing these
a lot uh
they're they're very interesting
applications in ai for this especially
when you start to have
multiple modes uh you know you might
have some text
you might have some image you might have
other kinds of data coming in all about
the same objects
but all of these are leveraging
different types of gradients
to distinguish and of course you know
there's also deep learning which is a
kind of supervised learning
uh i made the mistake about 40 years ago
of uh you know people warned me against
it but i went into a field called
machine learning in graduate school
and then i was also warned to stay away
from something but i i made the mistake
further
of studying a topic called neural
networks and uh i was fortunate i got to
do a lot of uh
r d work in neural networks including
hardware acceleration back in the 80s
and 90s
um it's really outstanding to see how
much neural networks have taken off
um you know but this is a way of
differentiating our input
reinforcement learning is another area i
really love working in
um and the idea there is it's really an
application of optimal control theory
but then it has deep learning bolted on
to be able to
learn the edge cases it's probably
pretty cool to see it you can have one
or more agents that are working within
an environment
environment may be simulated it may be
real but at the end of the day you've
you're training policies to recognize
again these different gradients
and how to get back to more of an
optimal kind of
performance weak supervision is another
area
uh really interesting when you see
projects like snorkel
uh that are leveraging this so sort of
how can we create mathematical functions
to describe our human experts
who are labeling data and then when we
train figure out the error and again
look at those gradients and figure out
which experts are good with particular
cases not so good with others
so how can we turn human judgment into a
kind of mathematical
labeling function and then again apply
machine learning on that gradient
uh on and on there's a lot of areas
i do a lot of work in knowledge graph
maybe we'll talk about that at a
different day but
it's a nice way to complement what's
going on in supervised learning or
self-supervised learning even
by having the context
and the last part it's a bit
slippery the definition meta learning is
something that's maybe not as well
defined
it's still much more of an active
research topic but the idea
there is uh what can we learn
from our past um the idea being that
as say we're working in a data science
team as we're going
and working with some organizations data
training models deploying them
collecting feedback from ml apps about
how the models perform
as we have some history collected over
time when we're confronted with a new
problem we have to go
build more machine learning to to help
you know solve that problem
can we learn from our past uh can we do
some data mining on our machine learning
history
and and sort of pull a lot of the pieces
together to be able to construct
better better training better models so
meta-learning is is kind of something
that pulls these together
and yeah okay so you know typically
there may be some human
loop aspects or some weak supervision
you may be using databases knowledge
graph for context
but it's really interesting where the
scope of meta learning is going
with respect to auto ml and so
the second part of this is you know when
you roll the clock back to
the definitions of a.i that were being
used in the 70s and 80s
and uh and i'm old enough to have been
in grad school
back in the 80s early 80s uh you know we
used to talk about ai
as search and so you you look up you
know some of the old papers and
discussions you'll you'll see a lot
about a-star and b-star and search
strategies and
and i can tell you that at stanford
computer science you know in
the ai work that was going on there in
the 80s it was just
always talking about search and
heuristics it's probably no
small wonder that you know one of the
spin-offs that came
out of that uh department was a little
company called google
focusing on search so at the end of the
day when we're working with
machine learning workflows we really
encounter a lot of search problems
um you know the challenge of building
machine learning models
finding the best hyper parameters for a
given use case given a set of data
it's not a simple task it's not
something that's particularly linear
there's a lot of non-linear
effects and complexities that can come
in a lot of challenges especially when
we start thinking about security and
privacy
fairness and bias compliance and a lot
of these other issues
um so there's a challenging search
problem when we're working with machine
learning workflows
uh and a lot of questions that need to
be asked
by the way i'm gonna have a lot of links
in the slides and i'll provide a pdf for
the slides
so hopefully there's some good resources
and some questions you can use later on
but anyway there's a number of questions
whenever we're working with machine
learning
and so if we think about formulating
this as a search problem
how can we answer these questions and
resolve these different caveats and
concerns
um that's a guidance toward how can we
use automl
what if it were possible to look at all
the different variations of the input
data
all the different possible variations of
the hyper parameters etc
and then search efficiently within those
to find how do we train models best for
a given situation
so that's a search problem and that's
what automl effectively is addressing
so you know find the appropriate hyper
parameters identify features and data
transformations that
produce optimal training sets and learn
from your history being able to have
feedback loops within your workflow in
your process uh
and you know there's other
considerations coming in too i i don't
know if you've seen but this is really
fascinating
uh on a couple fronts um energy and
policy considerations
uh for instance some of the large
transformer models with deep learning
turns out that you know they have
approximately five times
the lifetime carbon footprint of an
average automobile uh
just to train them um so there's a lot
of interesting
issues uh do we really wanna boil the
ocean and pump
carbon in the atmosphere just to have
slightly incrementally better machine
learning models probably not
we want to be cognizant of that also
there's the matter of
other trade-offs in machine learning
model because yeah i can
keep creating billion and trillion
perimeter models to have
you know a thousandths of a percentage
better accuracy yeah i can do that but
you know how much carbon do i burn how
long does it take before i can deploy
something in front of a customer
you know what are the resources required
for this in terms of
cost there's a lot of trade-offs and
sometimes simpler algorithms can be
better for a given case
there was research yesterday showing the
use of unsupervised graph techniques
versus gpt2 for being able to understand
uh essentially claims within text
where the the much smaller algorithms
ran three to four orders of magnitude
faster
and had better results uh so you know i
do want to underscore there's a lot of
trade-offs and this is a complex space
and and certainly when you get into
areas of like fairness and bias uh
there's some great resources af360 also
explainability
aix 360. a lot of areas of trust there
to consider
and you know the other thing that really
uh astounds me when you when you look at
machine learning
i hear a lot of people talk about
accuracy and and in fact i see a lot of
vendors where they describe they can
give you the best accuracy possible
but then when you go to evaluate what
they're what they're talking about
you know they'll just have like one kind
of metric that they're measuring or
maybe two
you know technically speaking when i
talk about accuracy with respect
to machine learning really i could break
that down into at least four different
areas of
precision and recall specificity
perplexity and then you get aggregate
scores like f1 that are weighted average
so you know it it's really complex and
accuracy alone is not really what you
want you you want
confidence versus uncertainty in terms
of your predictive results
you want to understand how much money
you're going to spend
uh and you know there will be
diminishing returns in terms of money in
terms of time
you want to understand about scalability
and resource footprint
privacy security compliance etc so
uh trying to find the best machine
learning model is not
easy um so in practice
actually there's a note here about life
cycle but
let me just show here the idea is let's
talk about
kind of an idealized uh
machine learning workflow say that
you've you've got some data preparation
of course we always spend a lot of time
doing that it's super important
and then we go into feature engineering
feature selection is
also difficult it's very hard provably
hard problem
and then from there once we can say
we've got our features we've built our
training sets
then we can go out and train optimized
learners
to you know run the algorithms to build
the models but then we also have a very
provably hard problem
of evaluating the results of models
because they aren't always apples to
apples comparison
and then even once you have a model or
an ensemble of models selected
there's there are issues in terms of
integration and deployment
because if you're going into something
that's say edge device or low power
you know you may have to make trade-offs
in your in your algorithm just to be
able
to fit inside of the hardware that's
required in the battery footprint
or you may have auto scaling issues
because you're deploying on a cluster
etc
so let's use this lifecycle model for a
kind of blueprint
and then compare where the automl
features are
emerging with respect to these
and by the way i i should mention also
there's there's kind of a a
a three-tier uh or a three-prong
uh evolution of things happening here
because
this this notion of automl also
intersects a lot with what's going on in
data governance
but at the same time it also intersects
a lot with what's emerging in terms of
mlaps practices and those three are
emerging together
um now uh i'm going to be
discussing uh you know basically an
aggregate of a number
of different projects being reviewed
there's uh
a google spreadsheet online that's open
to the public if you want to check it
out
i've been trying over the past couple
years to keep track of the different
open source projects in automl
as well as different vendors and just
you know keep a few notes about all of
them
um and certainly uh if anything needs to
be added let me know i'd love to i'm
trying to curate this
and add more so i'm sure there's
probably some changes that are required
even for what's shown there
um and uh
also uh you know i'll mention that i'm
drawing heavily from some other
resources
i highly recommend this from hyadaisian
there's something called awesome automl
papers
and it's updated curated quite often
a really great visualization and sort of
taxonomy
of the different areas of what's going
on and then links out to a lot of the
latest papers and projects
okay so having said that let's look
through this stage by stage
first off there's this area of our data
preparation
and in data science preferably we spend
80 percent of our time
here and that makes sense if if i was at
a hedge fund
in finance i would probably spend at
least 80 of my time curating my
portfolio
um similar thing in data science you
really want to curate your data
now there are some great examples of
like hollow clean and snorkel
areas where uh weak supervision is
being leveraged to help automate some of
the data preparation data cleaning
and so this is something that that could
have
a lot of impact because again so much of
our time is spent
uh in this stage when we're working in
uh data science
so i've got a a couple of papers here
a little bit reference but uh definitely
taking a look at whole clean i think is
something highly recommended
um and let me check because i think i
may see a question
uh chat
okay okay okay sorry sorry i just had to
trick through that there
um if i go to the next stage feature
engineering
uh the next stage in a typical in a life
cycle
um you know this is where we have to
pick out the features that really will
define the gradients that we're trying
to differentiate
and there can be effects between
features there can be non-linear effects
it could be that the raw features just
really don't
show how to differentiate the data
carefully you may need to transform them
first
and we don't need to go in the
mathematics for that right now but uh
it's a hard problem
um i definitely want to recommend a few
resources um
a couple of friends of mine alex yang
and amanda kasari
uh have a really great book called
feature engineering from machine
learning
highly recommended and in terms of going
deep dive into the math for feature
engineering alex
alice is a world expert on that so
highly recommended
um and i'd also want to point out
there's a great paper a friend of mine
you manchester um
kevin brown is one of the authors on
stability of feature
selection algorithms um and it's really
interesting because if you look at
selecting features in a given data set
as
say the customer base is evolving over
time as the data is evolving over time
how can statistically how can you choose
features
to be more stable in lieu of say
you know every week i'm going to train a
new model and i'm going to select
different features for whatever is best
that week
um you know that may be good for a point
in time of
increasing predictive power but it's not
good in terms of
understanding model drift and other
kinds of artifacts of machine learning
and practice over time
so i think that the stability of feature
selection algorithm
is really interesting and underused
technique
but there are some great points here in
terms of feature engineering automl
toolkit
mmobox and others are really
highlighting that
um now moving into the next stage where
we train the models
we assume we've got our training set our
test set we need to train our learners
this is where we get into the hyper
parameter optimization
and one thing i really want to strongly
clarify is when you talk about automl
some of the early discussions about
automl were only about hyper parameter
optimization
and there are still people out there who
are fairly dogmatic saying
that's all it is uh it's not true
there's much more than just
the hpo the hyper parameter optimization
and uh and that
and the other parts are maybe more
recent so that's one bit of
misunderstanding i want to clear up in
industry
this is super important this is where
you go and
select the hyper parameters you need to
do but it's not the entire problem
it is one though that's very
computationally intensive and so there's
some great examples here
um hyperopt auto keras is a little bit
older but
hyperopt uh ray tune is something newer
i do a lot of work with ray and uh
the tune component of of course is very
very important
so uh there's a great article here stop
doing
iterative model development uh from some
of my friends over at determined ai
i mentioned to meet tal walker a little
bit earlier he had
pioneered something called paleo
and and also some earlier projects um uh
amit and i used to work together at
databricks and and now he's got
determined ai
um okay so hpo is
kind of the heart of the thing but once
you've trained a bunch of models now you
need to understand
okay i've trained them but what do they
really mean what are the results really
mean how do i compare them
and and there's some examples of this in
auto second learn
um i think that you know talking about
ensembles is probably some of the better
dialogue about this in industry
uh combinations of multiple machine
learning models of course
this is a very powerful technique which
was highly uh accentuated during
the netflix prize competitions um
and then you know once you've got a
model
or an ensemble of model selected now we
need to look at
what are some of the issues once you go
to use it and of course this is where it
starts to intersect a lot into anal ops
practices
but the fact is deploying models is hard
um
once you deploy models almost as soon as
they're deployed they start degrading
and then lark and i have a article or
report about that out that just came out
today on gradient flow
um but you know when you look at
sagemaker and watson studio
and and and some of the other kinds of
services um they provide
uh really excellent resources in terms
of auto scaling
uh but then you know maybe in the other
direction your machine learning models
aren't going to be deployed on a really
large cluster in the cloud instead
they're going to be deployed on some
battery-operated device that's out in
the field
and then you want to look at you know
low-power kinds of situations
maybe you need to do some sort of model
distillation or other ways of shrinking
the footprint of the model and there are
great techniques for that
um tensorflow.js i think uh i'll shout
out uh
to uh some friends over there really
fantastic work
they are also some of the people doing
the tiny ml summit
if you haven't seen that that's an
excellent conference when you're looking
at low power ml
highly recommended um
okay so taking a look we have these
different stages of what we can do and
and there are some commercial properties
um again shout out to ibm for helping to
sponsor and
and donating to pi data we're very
grateful uh
when you look at some of the commercial
offerings
some of them really do uh try to be very
mindful and considerate about
this kind of end-to-end workflow
perspective and and offering features at
every stage of the machine learning
workflow
to leverage automotive kinds of features
so auto ai is one of the offerings out
of watson studio
and underneath the hood there there is
some open source that's helping to drive
that
and we'll show some some demos of that a
little bit later
um now looking ahead in terms
of automl um i would say
you know keep a close watch on this area
of
metal learning it's still somewhat of a
slippery definition but
it's it's definitely evolving very
rapidly
there's a great survey paper that came
out
about six months ago by um hospitales
at all it's called metal learning in
neural networks a survey
and there's a few others here that are
really good like overview
sorts of papers i'd reference
um essentially this is where we get into
more of the workflow perspective
of kind of semi-automated machine
learning across
the whole workflow and there's some good
examples of this in open source
um teapot is one that really took a stab
at that kind of automated data science
notion and lale is another one uh
lolli is the one that i'm going to show
some examples of and it's
some of the open source um coming out of
um
ibm pascal uh and uh
others and it's it's part of what's
driving the auto ai
offering
um you know another thing that i really
want to call out and this is something
that's not said a lot in the other
literature
but there's a lot of overlap between
this field of automl
and what's happening in program
synthesis um
and i really love this area of program
synthesis essentially using ai
to generate code for a given kind of
context
and you can go back to i mean for
instance
claire ledoux claire lagoo who's now at
cmu she had done
really fascinating work on genetic
algorithms
genetic algorithm usage for bug bounties
for github repos at scale
really fantastic work on what can be
done with program synthesis
and basically learning concepts in one
open source project but then apply them
to
uh fixed security security
vulnerabilities in other open source
projects
um and you know that it kind of fits
with the whole general trend of what
we're seeing and say
pre-commit hooks and a lot of like ast
analysis of
of code um i do a lot of python uh open
source code and you know we
we make use of uh pylint and and other
types of of these sort of pre-commit
tools
um which really intersect here um so the
idea is how can we use machine learning
to augment how people create
software um and there's some great
examples of this
um i if you haven't seen it definitely
check out autopandas
where you know if you have some data
frames in one shape and you need to get
them into a required
uh other shape uh autopandas can create
the python code for you to do that
um and there's also you know a lot of
deep learning tools in this area tab
nine
has great examples in terms of
autocompletion inside of
ides but this area of program synthesis
there's a lot going on
and uh you know there's also some
controversy
um there's a really fascinating uh video
that i'm linking here
uh about automl and some of the
rationale
it's jeff dean at google talking about
automl and how
you know basically a lot of companies
are facing
challenges trying to hire enough ai
experts and so
the idea was being floated is well we'll
just make automl much better
and then the companies would spend 100x
more in cloud
computation and not have to hire as many
people um
yeah and so i mean there's there's a
video of google talking about this it's
it's an interesting idea and to some
extent it's true but not entirely true
i think there's still going to be a lot
of jobs for ai experts
the other thing though you know another
kind of subtext that's going on
is that hardware has been evolving very
rapidly
and uh i i will i will show i don't have
a link unfortunately yet they haven't
published it
but uh yesterday we just got a new mini
book out on manning
that's called uh hardware is uh
actually i can show this a little bit
later there's a new
mini book out on manning that dean
wampler and i did working with
some of the open source tech leads at
nvidia um
really understanding how to have good
design patterns
with idiomatic python so that hardware
can really optimize
what your workflows are trying to do and
of course this fits in very much with
automl
because it's so compute uh intensive but
also in some areas very bandwidth
intensive
um okay so a lot of resources here i
highly recommend
um in conclusion you know mine the
caveats
the ethical and policy considerations
there's a lot more than just
optimizing hyperparameters it's a much
bigger field a lot more implications
um and definitely check out what's going
on with hardware because there's a lot
going on there
so automl is a lot about basically
training
ai to improve ai um
now having said that let me shift over i
would like to
show some examples of this based on the
lale project
the idea with the demos is i want to
point you towards some resources
i'm not going to run them because i am
concerned that since i'm very remote i'm
out in the redwoods
i don't want zoom to interact with my
cpu when i'm trying to run something
um so let me let me just talk through
and show some of this
um so this is the lale project
and if you go inside of lale i'm running
this in jupiter lab
um actually let me show la la project is
right here
um lale is a persian word
uh i'm half version uh but it's also the
name for a python library for
semi-automated data signs
um and so anyway i go into lale
and i go into the examples and then
there's a number of different
i uh jupiter notebooks that show how to
work with lale
um i will show in here about
uh hyperparameter optimization um and so
let me describe this just real quickly
la la is about creating a grammar to
describe
what you would like to see in a machine
learning workflow
and then using la la using automl
to optimize uh within those constraints
so how can you figure out the best
selections at each stage of your
workflow
so here okay what we do is
we use a pipe as a kind of combinator
uh where you make a different choice uh
to select so we'll start out a pipeline
saying
we're either going to do a nice drum or
or
or nothing at all as a first stage in
data preparation
and then from there we're going to have
another stage where we look at
are we using logistic regression versus
k neighbors and then we'll take and
visualize that
and then we'll run some optimization on
it
and the idea is that you're using
machine learning to look at this
the different selections the different
points of the workflow
until you can come out with okay what's
best
now i can visualize this another example
would be
here uh okay here's where we've got a
top k
classifier and psychic learn and we're
going to throw in a few different
options at different stages of the
workflow
so basically what we do is we want to
come out with
uh tupcake we want to come up with three
different models we use an ensemble
and we have different options that we
can plug into those and here you can see
the different options being visualized
by wale
and you run through and you do your
training and it comes out with okay what
are the best selections that we can have
for building this ensemble and
similarly um you know if you if you want
to look at
issues such as fairness and bias here's
where you can do some
some integration of lale socket learn
and af 360. um to understand do we have
imbalance in the data sets we're
introducing bias or we're using
protected classes where we shouldn't be
and so here we can build up a pipeline
that takes the bias issues into into
account as well as selecting
what types of algorithms we should be
using the different stages
and you can see the visualization of
what's being being selected
um so i will throw that out there
and then the other thing that i'll put
out is a little bit of a plug
if you want to learn more about what's
going on on the hardware side and how to
do idiomatic python
to really support a lot of say gpu
optimization
but also scale out on cpus etc there's a
new mini book out it's free
it's called hardware is greater than
software is greater than then process
data science and post-moore's law
um the other thing let's see definitely
i'll put in a plug for automl.org and
for awesome automl papers um
another thing that i'll put out a plug
for is if you haven't seen calm code
from
vincent warmerdam uh you know when
you're talking about optimizing
workflows and week supervision
and human in the loop uh vincent's got
some really great examples
so at that i will stop talking
and stop sharing the screen and get back
into questions
thank you parker are there questions
from the audience feel free to unmute
yourself
and speak to the speaker directly or ask
the questions in the chat
and let me throw out a question too to
start out with
have you tried using any auto auto ml
tools i'd love to hear some stories
about if
if you've tried any of these out
i've tried to use it sage maker and
gcp and uh also azure and i'm not a
great coder
and i'm not wanting to be a great coder
i mean i would like to be that but
uh you know it really kind of is amazing
to me to get some pretty good results
just by throwing some data in there and
you can kind of start with just throwing
data in there and get an answer
all the way up to being really specific
about your code
and that's probably why i want to hear
your talk i'm very fascinated by what's
going on
and how that can democratize data i'm in
the ad industry i'm a copywriter
and so i think a lot of people could use
this who aren't data scientists
oh well said i love hearing that uh uh
thank you less you know i really think
that's kind of the sweet spot for where
this really appeals and has
so much impact is because um yeah we we
have ai systems that are smart enough to
train other ai systems
they're good enough you know and i mean
you're not trying to write a paper for
neurops you know or or beat the next
kaggle competition um you're trying to
get a job done
and you need to get that done in a
certain amount of time in your industry
um and you probably don't want to spend
20 million dollars training a billion
parameter
model yeah the basic thing in
advertising is let's see something by
five this afternoon
exactly yeah yeah and that's what this
really helps and you know
i think that there are energy
considerations on this policy
considerations that
if we can use the hardware effectively
we can train with less resources
which means less carbon footprint which
also means faster results
uh to to fit the business case so i
think that these
these kinds of you know long-term goals
are really aligning
thank you
you know the other thing i'll say is uh
i do have friends on on some of those
other teams some of the cloud
cloud vendors uh that were being
mentioned certainly on sagemaker
um so i'll shout out to them uh there's
a lot of great work
across things across uh google cloud
platform
azure alibaba uh aws ibm et cetera
um you know it's interesting because
they really do leverage a lot of the
open source
um there's kind of this pipeline from
like research
to open source to you know cloud
offering
uh that that's very active so you can
kind of get a feel for what's happening
in the
in the research if you're looking at the
papers although more and more you can
even get a leading signal by watching
github
to see what papers are going to get
published because probably the github
repo comes out before the publication
um so you know it's kind of a heads up
for what's coming down the pipeline
um it it does take time to create a
robust
service offering in the cloud i've been
working with amazon since they launched
and uh you know to make something that's
democratizing a new technology
but works in a very robust way for a
large amount of people
it doesn't happen overnight um and so
there's some lag
between what the latest research is and
what what the latest offerings are doing
but these teams are doing really well to
bring this out um
and it's it's just it's getting better
over time
any more questions from the audience
let me ask one quickly i regularly teach
machine learning to practitioners you
know applied machine learning
not algorithm engineering and i always
wonder how much this is going to change
when order ml goes mainstream like a lot
of the typical
curriculum you know is focused on
searches over algorithms models and
hyper parameters
and these are the easiest parts to
automate and the first parts to
become automated uh what's your
perspective on this how much is this
going to change
teaching machine learning yeah that's a
really good question
um yeah i mean just for some of my
background i led data teams in industry
for about 10 years
and so um you know having to be the
manager the director level manager who's
answering to executives but
also coaching a lot of people to be
building machine learning uh
projects all day every day um it's a lot
like teaching
and i do some teaching on the side too
so i can really empathize
um you know i think the big takeaway is
that a lot of the stuff that we spent
our time on was really busy work it's
just
it had to be done it had to be done
right um it was something that
clearly even going back to 2011 you know
steven boyd and others were pointing out
a lot of this busy work could be done by
machines and then we can use
our brain power our communication skills
our social uh
abilities to understand the harder parts
of the problem
because i i think that you know my my
experience teaching in industry
when i like going back to like 2014 i
was doing a lot of
machine learning courses in industry and
uh it still wasn't quite catching
it was only after that point where it
really picked up
um but you know people were interested
in the nuts and bolts
and if you talked about ethics nobody
wanted to hear about it
um you know you talked about security
and it's like well that's just too
obscure
but these days you know we see what's
happened over the past several years
with
large scale adoption of machine learning
and there are social considerations
there's a lot of huge impact on people
um so i i think that yeah let's have
machines do the busy work
and let's focus on the hard problems
involving security and privacy
and collaboration and compliance and
fairness
because these are things that can't be
computed away and they're also things
that are just
they're organizationally very hard and
so we need people to understand
other people and problems in history
and law to be able to overcome some of
those kinds of challenges so i'm
i'm hopeful that in some ways automl
frees up the busy work so that we can
take on the harder tasks um i also i
work a lot in an area of
knowledge graphs and this is something
we're seeing in industry
actually i work a lot with some german
firms in
knowledge graph and you know this is the
thing where they're trying to address
uh challenges in data across different
parts of the organization
and it's a very human problem and it's
not something that a machine learning
model can solve
so i i like this idea that people can be
more people this way great answer
so dennis is quickly asking uh can you
make the slides available
yes uh you know i made some last minute
changes and so i will cut a pdf and post
that
i can send it mail it to you or i can
just post it uh on the
uh on the meetup comments
i think mida comments work fine okay
great
okay well thank you everybody i really
appreciate it
thanks paco thank you guys thanks parker
appreciate it oh my pleasure